Great. Um, so hey everyone. It's great
to see you all. Uh, I'm Andrew. I'm the
head of the AI security team at Stripe.
Um, and I've been at Stripe for about 10
years now. And I mean, I guess a lot of
people ask me why I'm still here. Uh,
unfortunately, I'm a nerd who loves
solving problems and I've yet to find
another uh, way to keep my ADHD brain
entertained. Um, but in these 10 years,
I've lived through, you know, many
product launches, many reorgs, um, you
know, the slow, dignified graying of
Patrick's hair. Um, and I can honestly
say that this moment, um, sort of this
work in security, um, in this age of AI
is some of the most exciting work that,
you know, I've I've experienced in my
entire career. And so I'm here to talk
to you about the uh possibly most
exciting and also most terrifying aspect
of uh being in this new AI age which is
prompt injection and sort of the
approaches that we're taking at Stripe
to mitigating the risk there.
Um so we have an elephant in the room.
Um, you know, I I think in this
community, we spend a lot of time
thinking and talking about prompt
injection, but I find that most people
working in AI are sort of scrupulously
avoiding it. Um, you know, given the AI
hype cycle, all the focus on building
things really, really fast, there's not
a lot of consideration of risk. We're
very much back in a move fast and break
things era. Um, and it's just easier for
a lot of companies to pretend prompt
injection doesn't exist and hope there
won't be a problem. Um, which ultimately
means just letting the user, you know,
beware the risk to to them. You know,
see, open claw, of course. Um, and so
while I'm sure everyone here, uh, you
know, understands prompt injection quite
well, I've actually been very surprised
at how many other, you know, people in
AI, you know, experienced AI developers,
you know, startup founders, tech
executives that I talk to only have a
really vague understanding of what
prompt injection is. Um, because
ultimately prompt injection is a really
inconvenient risk. Um and that's why I
think we as a security uh you know as
security practitioners have a really
important um responsibility to show to
the industry that not only is it uh um
you know a real risk but it does not
actually um mean that we can't move fast
on AI. We need to help you know all of
our companies you know the people
building AI move fast while not yoloing
security.
So, you know, I'm sure a lot of you have
um seen this graph from last year about
uh failure rates um in resisting prompt
ejection attacks. Um you know, models
are getting better. But I think in
security, you know, even a 1% even a
0.1% failure chance to attack is not
enough. So, we need something better. We
need something better than just uh
relying on the models. And also, this is
not a future problem. Um, another
elephant that is hiding behind the first
elephant is that we don't really know
um, especially with consumers how
prevalent prompt ejection attacks are
and we don't know how prevalent that
they are going to be in the future. But
I personally believe that um, you know,
once again looking at things like open
claw things are going to get a lot worse
before they get better. Um, so what do
we do? Um, you know, how do we protect
our companies from the risks of prompt
injection? Um, well, I I have a
confession to make. I'm not here to
announce a magical technical solution
that allows us to solve prompt injection
without any risk. I'm going to tell you
something that you probably already
know, which that we basically have to
assume prompt injections will happen and
prevent compromised agents from causing
harms uh compromised agents from causing
harm when they do happen. Um, but I will
share with you a set of architectural
controls that we have built at Stripe
that serve as guardrails to prevent
those bad things from happening when
prompt injection does happen.
But the guardrails are really only a
small part of the story. Um,
what happens when you put these
guardrails in place is that there are
negative impacts on sort of what agents
can do. There's friction for users.
addressing those problems is really what
takes um sort of a technical solution
into a workable solution for your
business. Um and you know that's sort of
the the real work I think in many cases
of security practitioners.
This is sort of ultimately a security
leadership talk. you know, when
practicing a security engineering, you
know, step one is the threat model, step
two is the mitigation, but importantly,
step three is figuring out how to put in
place the mitigation in a way that the
business still can achieve its goal. Um,
and so with prompt injection, the
interesting part is what happens uh
after we put in place the guard rails,
how do we enforce it? Um, and uh, you
know, what do we do to make it so that
agents can still be powerful? Um and and
so I'm going to uh tell you a little bit
about how we've tried to uh uh navigate
the sort of frothy FOMO driven world um
uh while still remaining secure.
Um cool. So what are the controls? Okay.
Well, first let's start with data
exfiltration. What are the two bad
things that can happen when you get
prompt injected? Um I'm sure you're all
familiar with the lethal trifecta. You
know, this term coined by Simon Willis.
Um you know there are three things that
a agent needs in order to um uh
exfiltrate data if it gets prompt
injected. Um one is untr untrusted
content. Untrusted content is really not
feasible in most cases I think for us to
um you know remove as a guard rail. Um,
you know, first of all, a big part of
why LLMs are useful in the first place
is you can just throw a bunch of stuff
at them and they will figure out what to
do. And beyond that, um, you know,
attackers have been very very creative
in figuring out, uh, ways to sneak
prompt injections into places you
wouldn't think to look for untrusted
content. Um, similarly, there's private
data. And while there are totally many
applications that don't need private
data to work, uh there are a lot that
do. And certainly at Stripe, we have a
lot. You know, whether it's support
tickets, emails, etc. Many, many agents
need private data, which means that
there's really only one leg of the
lethal trifecta that we can focus on for
um mitigating prompt injection risk,
which is egress. So um our focus has
been um from a guardrail perspective
very much on preventing egress which one
is egress to the public internet just
making general web requests and then
there's another sneaky one which is
being really careful about how you talk
to third parties. Um you know a very
easy way to excfiltrate data would be
writing it to a public Google doc with a
Google doc tool. Um so that's guard
wheel one preventing egress.
Second, unfortunately, there isn't a uh
you know term officially for uh the
things that you need in order to have
prompt injection um deal damage by
taking a sensitive action. But I guess
lacking something better, I will call
this the lethal bifecta. Um and
essentially we're in the same boat where
um preventing untrusted content is not
really that feasible for most agents. So
instead um we focus on uh preventing
agents from unilaterally taking
sensitive actions. Um sensitive is very
loadbearing here. Um generally the rule
of thumb that I say is that anything
that is a production right or exter like
a um broad communication or or sending a
message are the big things that we think
of as as sensitive actions.
So uh great problem solved. We have our
guard rails. Um, unfortunately, um,
these guardrails cause problems. Um,
they cause agents to be less useful and
worse, they cause agents to be very
annoying. Um, I'm sure everyone here has
had a very similar experience using
claude code for the first time where um,
you know, Claude is constantly asking,
can I do this? Can I do this? Can I do
this? And it really is a bad user
experience. you just start trying to you
know find where in the settings you can
enable dangerously skip permissions. So
we really need to address these pain
points if we want um these guardrails to
be adoptable.
So let's start with egress controls. Um
you know the common thing that I heard a
lot of when I was like hey we need to
make it so our agents can't egress to
the public internet is like wait you
know we need to be able to do research
we need access to public internet data.
Um the key thing here is that what these
agents generally need is not the ability
to make an arbitrary HTTP request. What
they need is the ability to get data
from the internet. So the solution that
we came to here is to offer a safe
search. Um we build this on OpenAI
search. Um but you know there are other
ways to do this. Um but the key thing
here is you need to make it so that the
search does not itself um trigger
egress. So there's a setting in OpenAI
web search uh external web access false
that you set so that you can make a
request for a search and it'll just
serve results to you out of the cache
and it won't um you know you prevent the
uh data from being eressed by your agent
and instead it just gets egressed by
OpenAI. That's not like really making
anything any safer.
So second is um how you um handle SAS.
So, you know, we say, "Hey, we have to
be careful about egress." And then
people are like, "Well, I have an MCP
for my SAS app. Can't I just hook up the
SA uh the MCP?" That's fine, right? We
trust our SAS. And that's sort of true,
but also sort of not true. Um the way
that we have approached, you know,
preventing um SAS from being a data
exfiltration vector is through proxying.
Um we have a central MCP server at
Stripe called Toolshed. Basically when
we want to hook up a uh thirdparty SAS
we will uh proxy basically the
connection through that central uh
server and then that gives us a place
where we can write rules like don't
allow connections to tenants that are
not stripe um when you're uh writing
data to Google Docs or Figma or
whatever. Um and ultimately this
actually offers a better experience for
the user because then they only need to
worry about connecting to one MCP server
with their app. Um
and so second we have uh the human
confirmation friction. Um this is an
area I think that there really needs to
be a lot more user experience uh
research. But at a high level I think of
there being like three main problems um
when you're doing human confirmation
flow. One is that like especially in
this sort of claude code umesque world
that we are in now, the fact that the
confirmation dialogue stops the agent in
its tracks is a major problem. You
really want to be able to start an agent
doing its work and let it you know churn
along until it's done and then come back
to it. Um second is review fatigue. You
know see claude code asking you to run
find. Um and uh third is rubber
stamping. you know, with enough review
fatigue, people are just going to mash
confirm on any confirmation dialogues.
So, as we've been looking at the UX for
this, I think that um probably the core
of how we can make this a lot better for
users is batching confirmations. Um
there are a lot of like writes and
commands that you might want to do that
don't really actually need to happen
instantaneously for the agent to
continue making for forward progress.
So, we can just let these stack up on
the side and let the user come back to
these later.
Um secondly, there are a lot of uh
rights where you can just do the right
and then offer the user the opportunity
to revert it later and that's like a
perfectly reasonable uh compromise to
make sure that the agent can't um you
know do some irreversible harm. Um and
then also as we um sort of continue to
get into um you know more sophisticated
policy there are a lot of options around
having an LLM as a second reviewer to
make sure that people aren't rubber
stamping things to you know uh uh
quickly tell the agent that it's trying
to do something bad um you know uh uh
without needing to involve the human.
So lastly, how do we enforce this all?
This is like very challenging when you
have many many people um writing agents
in uh different frameworks um across um
your ecosystem.
Um for egress uh fortunately we're in
really good shape here at Stripe because
we have a strong egress control program
that predated sort of the world of AI
agents. We have a uh open source
repository called smokeokescreen that we
use for a lot of this. Uh essentially
the approach here is one tag any service
that is an AI agent. This is actually
not very hard because we know that to be
an agent, you need to talk to foundation
models. We have a proxy for this, but
you could use, you know, whether your
service talks to bedrock or whatever as
a way of doing this. And then once you
have uh a tag on the services that are
agents, you know where your egress proxy
serve uh service is or you know how your
firewall is con uh figured, you can just
write CI checks that say if this is an
agent, you can't configure uh egress
without some you know escalated uh uh
review process to make sure it's
following um sort of the principles of
uh um you know preventing data
exfiltration. So that's essentially what
we do at Stripe.
So for guardrails things are a little
bit more complicated. Um at Stripe we
have sort of two main places that people
are writing tools. Um either you're
writing inline tools in the agent
framework or you're writing tools that
are in our central MCP service. And our
approach here is that we require
annotations on every tool with you know
nice human readable properties like
production impacting write or broadcast
uh data internally. And then based on
these annotations you can determine
whether the tool needs to have some sort
of human in the loop review. And by sort
of centralizing this through a
framework, you can have a central uh um
UX framework that is used for um you
know doing those reviews and sort of
improving the experience on it over
time. Um things are getting more
complicated here though because um you
know I I've heard it said by certain
people that MCP is dead. Maybe not true,
but increasingly agents don't need
special tools. they'll just write their
own co code and hit their own um you
know hit random uh uh APIs on your
existing services. So what do we do
here? Um this is like work that is in
progress right now. of the approach that
we're looking at here is essentially
proxying the connections coming out of
agents out of their sandboxes and then
using that as a choke point where you
can similarly have annotations on the
API endpoints that the um agents are
talking to and determine which ones are
sensitive which ones need um additional
uh uh review by the the operator.
So yeah to to wrap up um we basically
derisk prompt injection by assuming it
will happen and preventing damage. Um
you know two risks data exfiltration and
harmful actions. Data excfiltration the
key control is preventing egress and
making sure that sna SAS isn't a sneaky
way to do egress. Um we solve pain
points here with uh safe web search and
proxying of SAS. Um and we use CI time
controls on egress settings as our
enforcement mechanism for preventing
harmful actions. Human review is the key
constraint. Um we use annotations in
order to ensure things have human review
um and trigger automatic human in the
loop. But we need to work hard to ensure
that the user experience of the human uh
in the loop flow is good and things like
batching, reverts um you know software
and LLM driven uh um checks that can
happen without uh the human being
involved all can be applied to make this
better.
Um so that's it. That's what we built.
Um, but at some level, what I really
want you to take away from this is that
security isn't just about figuring out
the secure way to do things. It's about
helping your organization figure out how
to accomplish uh their goals in a secure
way. Um and um you know it is slightly
terrifying to see all the offensive
talks of ways that uh um uh you know AI
is making it easier to attack things but
it's also been really um exciting to see
the ways in which I think we can expect
security to be much better in the near
future once we have agents really doing
all of this detailed analysis of our
code on an ongoing basis. But in order
to get there, we need to make it past
this sort of turbulent
high-risk era that we're in. And
basically uh uh all of us in this room
are the ones that need to help our
organizations do it. So thank you.
Questions? We got one back there. Uh
while I'm walking back, I'll start with
one. um uh you put a lot of effort into
improving the pain points around
uh sort of human in the loop reviews. Do
you find that there's any value in sort
of aggregating any of that at the the
group or team level or teams like
typically running into the same sorts of
problems or is it is it sort of like
person or or no review at all?
>> I think we're probably going to get
there. We're pretty early in this. a lot
of the the UX experimentation is like
very um you know very early on. We're
we're early on in the experimentation
process. But I think in general trying
to find ways to um you know make it so
that people need to stop less, fewer
checks, fewer reviews need to be made
while ensuring that human judgment is
applied at the right time is going to be
sort of the northstar here.
>> Awesome. Thank you. Quick question. Do
you still find the value in doing like
threat med to stop like prompt
objections at least partially as you
design systems?
>> Yeah, I think that there's 100% a place
for um you know detective and and um
sort of other types of controls that u
sort of are not um you know guarantees.
Um, I think especially for sort of
customerf facing products and stuff like
that that's is going to be important.
But like ultimately I guess because
we're not at the point where we can
fully trust that we really want to lean
on these more deterministic um
architectural controls.